patrice leconte les bronzés ou le nouvel
humour venue du café-théâtre sur le club
gym adaptée par même faire un film dans
le metteur en scène était et réalisateur
était et patrice levan
non
des crustacés au départ pièces de café
théâtre est venu un film mais est avant
tout nous tous un fil
oubliez pas chaque instant au tournage à
se dire non tu le fais vraiment tu joues
pour le splendide et là on est au cinéma
dont il n'est pas du tout cette
adaptation de jeu après un point énorme
touche par les cheveux et puis il ya une
différence énorme en plus de dire oh la
la c'est que c'est sidérant c'est que
l'entente terre de cinéma il ya la
différence gigantesque nommé de la
caméra et non par exemple ça paraît
banal de dire ça au cinéma sans la
caméra à ses rayons c est parce que je
mets au défi les gens qui verront ce
film
et s'ils ne savent pas que c'était une
pièce de café à un défi pour 2 dire de
cinéma est même né le ça n'est pas un
film de café t as à dire au sens il va
fouiller pose non sans cynisme on essaye
d'aligner des trucs parce que c'est dur
mais c'est un peu drôle et parfaire ma
tête épouvantable vous laissez pas cher
john rawls voilà nous faisait ce qu'il
voulait faire
je pense que l'exemple patent et ça me
semble difficile de taille ces histoires
des bronzés c'est l'histoire
du chef des sports qui est un jeu ou du
coq que je joue qui est un mec super bon
c'est tout et c'est à qui se lève tout
les gonzesses et c'est ça c'est son
histoire pendant une semaine du club que
j'ai pu dire c'est ça le principal non
non non non je rétablisse la vérité
importante l'histoire principale du film
est restée sur principal du film c'est
l'histoire de mon personnage et de son
personnage il ya un jeune médecin
dynamique et une jeune secrétaire qui
passent une semaine de vacances au club
qui ne se connaissent pas au début qui
va s'adonner davanture parallèle qui
finiront pas terminée enfin se retrouver
en sport portant tous en fait notre
ennemi mortel en fait pas tant on voit
les films on s'aperçoit très vite que le
personnage principal s'appelle jean
claude dusse c'est moi qu'ils jouent et
ceux jean claude dusse c'est un type qui
va au club en côte d'ivoire
principalement intéressé par le côté
drague comme une peau spécialement
adroit et en plus il est dans un milieu
de gens bronze et un peu musclé orthez
qu évidemment ça marche pas très bien
c'est comme rentrer à paris
l'endroit d'où il est en fait c'est lui
le plasma vaut bien que il s'accrocha
sur deux choses parce que sinon pendant
6,6 en face à murcie est incroyable
essaye tous de se mettre en avant alors
que le héros du film c'est mon
personnage c'est un type qui arrive qui
sentant une personne et gerald qui
râlent contre tout le monde en fasse
vraiment il a beaucoup de mal à
s'adapter aux circonstances et à
buzançais visons les entendent pas ce
qu'ils vont faire un coucou quand on
voit le film si les principaux
personnages qui font vibrer les gens
qu'il faut que les attendrissent et le
couple que nous formons gérard et moi
par exemple
bernard je veux dire que là à l'époque
pour tous les films j'avais pas mes
lunettes et pas enrhumé jetez plus mince
et énormément et c'est le couple
principal du résultat d' aventure c'est
formidable on est on défend évidemment
c'est l'histoire de dix personnages
principaux et que ces dix personnages
principaux avec les autres une
esthéticienne vieille fille aigrie
souhaita un animateur de cabaret par des
rennais luis rego
mais luis rego et que on s'est trop dans
cette histoire du vélo mais au bout du
compte c'est un travail d'équipé
[Musique]